the dance of dragons a true telling by
Grand Meer monin being a history of the
war of targaryan succession between the
princess fera and Aon second of his name
that nearly destroyed the
realm the dance of the Dragons a stupid
name for a targaryan civil war where my
ancestors danced away my Birthright
before the war house targaryan count had
18 Dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens we would never
be as powerful or as feared again all
right my friends in this video we're
going to have a look at HBO's new
official teaser for the Game of Thrones
series House of the Dragon that's right
ladies and gentlemen HBO released a new
video featuring The One and Only George
R Martin in the new video George R
Martin shows us some of the lands of Ice
and Fire that will be highlighted in
House of the Dragon second season it's
essentially a geography lesson on some
of of the locations in Westeros we will
see when House of the Dragon airs on HBO
and HBO Max again this summer although
we don't get any new information in the
video I still thoroughly enjoy hearing
George R Martin discuss the incredible
world he has created now as you all know
it's no secret house of the Dragon will
focus on what's happening in and around
King's Landing as House Targaryen fights
over the Iron Throne during the dance of
the Dragons now at the beginning of this
new teaser George R Martin shows us
where King's Landing dragon Stone and
the stepstones are located on the map of
Westeros most of you should immediately
recognize where King's Landing is
located it's one of the most significant
locations in Game of Thrones in House of
the Dragon considering it's where the
Iron Throne resides some of the greatest
moments in Game of Thrones and even
House of the Dragon were shot inside its
red key now if you look out over the
Blackwater Bay you will also see an area
known as the gallet nestled up right
alongside the islands of driftmark and
dragon Stone as I'm sure most of you are
already know drift Mark is the seat of
house valeron and Dragonstone is the
seat of rera Targaryen and House of the
Dragon they were heavily featured in
House of the Dragons first season and
I'm sure we will see many more scenes
there again during the new one in fact
the final scene of House of the dragon's
first season was on Dragonstone as rira
found out her son Luc car's valeron was
slaughtered by Amon one ey and his
enormous Dragon vagar Aon Rose through
the clouds and Below him the mon ous
vagar vagar was five times the size of
arax and the hardened Survivor of aund
battles vagar caught him above
shipbreaker Bay Watchers on the castle
walls saw distant blasts of flame and
heard a shriek drown out the
Thunder Prince luk harist fell broken to
be swallowed by the waves with his death
the war of ravens came to an end and the
war of Fire and blood
began then George R Martin shows us the
small independent Islands known as the
stepstones they are what's left over
from the land bridge that once connected
Dorne and Os now according to Legend the
arm of Dorne once connected Westeros and
esos the broken arm and the stepstones
were created when the arm of Dorne was
shattered by the breaking the usage of
the Hammer Of The Waters by the children
of the forest it happened thousands of
years ago when they were fighting the
first men and after it was shattered by
The Hammer of the waters the sea Rose
and swallowed the land that was once
here the only thing that remains are
these small Islands as I'm sure most of
you remember this is where Damon
Targaryen defeated the crab feeder in
the first season of House of the Dragon
we might see this location again in the
new season when the sea snake goes back
down there now since Lord corus valeron
is a merchant and makes most of his
wealth out on the sea he's often
affected by what's happening down there
in the stepstones in this new teaser GE
R Martin also highlights the disputed
lands in three of its free cities leas
Meir and tyros these cities were once
enemies for a very long time and they've
been fighting over their lands for
hundreds of years well in House of the
Dragon they've actually set down their
swords and finally formed an alliance by
making their own government known as the
triarchy some of this was already set up
in the first season Lord coros valeron
obviously wants to smash their Alliance
to free up the stepstone so he can sail
East again although the crab feeder was
defeated in the first season the war
isn't over in the stepstones I don't
think we've seen the end of that
storyline just yet now last but
certainly not least George R Martin
discusses the infamous and historical
event known as the Doom of valyria it
was an event that happened roughly 400
years before the events in Game of
Thrones or about 200 years before House
of the Dragon it's essentially what set
in motion the series of events that
would lead to House Targaryen arriving
in Westeros now for some reason that's
still a mystery to this day valyria
exploded setting fire to everything in
sight on the day of the Doom every Hill
for 500 miles exploded filling the air
with Ash and smoke and fire which killed
even the dragons not only that but there
were earthquakes that destroyed
everything while the Lakes boiled or
turned to acid the 14 Flames the fiery
mountains of valyria sent molten rock
thousands of feet into the air and red
clouds rained down dragon glass now
what's really interesting about this is
about 12 years before the Doom of
valyria Lord Anar targaryen's Maiden
daughter danise the dreamer had a dream
along with some visions that valyria
would explode foreseeing the Doom she
convinced her father to leave valyria
before the cataclysm thankfully her
father Anar set sail moving House
Targaryen and their five dragons to the
island of dragon Stone this is how and
why we still see House Targaryen in
Westeros during the the dance of the
Dragons I'm not sure if we will see
valyria in House of the Dragon but we
did get a glimpse of it in Game of
Thrones back in season
5 you know what they
say the Doom still rules
Vala what about the demons and the
Flames aren't you afraid of the
Doom many fans believe this is where
Dron flew D naris at the end of Game of
Thrones While others hoped she was taken
to valantis for canara to resurrect I
came to help daer storn is the one who
was
promised from the fire she was reborn to
remake the
world
yes valyria is only one of the many
mysterious locations I wish we could
learn more about in a song of vice and
fire hopefully Game of Thrones will
release more videos like these as we
wait for the new season of House of the
Dragon while this might not have been
your standard teaser from HBO I still
loved it because I'm always interested
in hearing George R Martin disc discuss
His Amazing Creation hopefully they will
release another video with actual images
from the new season soon now that
everything is done filming make sure you
subscribe that way you're the first to
know whenever I release a new video
there will always be a lot more heading
your way as always I want to thank
everyone for watching this one I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
oh